The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today's focus is
probability and statistics.
So let's start with
probability.
Let's look at probability
for binary variables.
What do you mean by
a binary variable?
It can take only two outcomes.
So it can take only
two values.
For example, it could be 0 or
1, head or tail, on or off.
So we are going to call this
variable A, for instance.
So A could be H, or A is equal
to T. But that could happen.
That event could happen with
a certain probability.
So by that, I mean the
probabilities, like we are
expressing the belief that the
particularly event could happen.
So we could assign
a value to that.
That is the probability
of A taking value H.
So here, the values
of A and B--
sorry, here, the value of A can
be either H or T, which
means it has only two
possible outcomes.
That's why we call it
a binary variable.
However, P of A is equal to H
can lie anywhere from 0 and 1,
including 0 and 1.
AUDIENCE: They don't
have to be even?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: They don't
have to be even?
PROFESSOR: Even?
AUDIENCE: Even chance, even
probability, like the same.
PROFESSOR: Sorry, I didn't
get your question.
AUDIENCE: Even though they're
binary, don't you need be able
to have the same probability?
PROFESSOR: OK, we'll
look at that later.
Like, this particular event
can take a particular
probability.
And we'll look at that
particular case later.
But in general, a probability
will always lie
between 0 and 1.
And it can take any value
between 0 and 1 since the
range it can take is continuous,
sorry discrete.
However, the value the variable
can take is going to
be discrete.
It can take only H or T. So
that's why you call it a
binary variable.
For example, take
a deck of cards.
Here, the value could be, for
example if you consider only
one particular suit,
then it can be any
one of those 13 values.
So there, this variable
is not binary.
However, the probability of a
particular event happening is
always between 0 and 1.
Now, let's look at some
probability, like what you
asked earlier is whether they
will be equal, whether the
probably of head and
tail can be equal.
So let's represent the
probability of A of H. This
can be between 0 and 1.
What is the probability
of A not happening?
So we call it by A bar.
Given P of A, can you
give me P of A bar?
AUDIENCE:1 minus P of A.
PROFESSOR: 1 minus P of A.
If there are two events
happening, for example, you're
throwing two coins, then we
can consider their joint
probabilities.
So let's say we have a coin, A,
and this coin, B. So this
coin can take two values.
And so this coin can take
another two values.
Sorry.
We know A can take H with
probability, say I assume it's
unbiased, so it'll be 1/2.
All these are going to be 1/2.
What's the probability of HT?
So now, we are considering a
joint event, P of A is equal
to H and P of B is equal to
T. So in probability, we
represent it by something
like this.
P A- do you know what is that?
P A intersection B, you want
both events to happen.
That will be P of A. And in this
case, it's P of B. So we
could simply say it's 1/4.
Why is this possible?
It's because these two events
are independent.
The coin A getting head
doesn't affect
coin B getting a tail.
So it doesn't have
any influence.
That's why these two events
are independent.
The dependent events are a
bit complex, to analyze.
Let's skip them at the moment.
So we know all these
probabilities
are going to be 1/4.
So we looked at a particular
condition here.
That is, A taking head
and B taking tail.
What about the condition, what
about the case where either A
or B takes a head?
How can we represent that?
So it will be something like A
is equal to H or B is equal to
H. Oh, probability at least
1, so by that, I can also
represent something like this.
OK, here, this is sufficient
anyway.
So what are the possibility
events?
So these three events could give
rise to this probability.
It's better if you can represent
this in a diagram.
So let's go and represent
This is A and this is B
getting, say, head.
In one case, both
can take head.
That is, this particular
condition, intersection we
earlier looked at.
So what is this whole thing?
That is, either A gets
H or B gets H,
which is this condition.
We call it P of A union B. Ok.
Is there an efficient way of
finding this rather than
writing down all
possible cases?
Is there an efficient way of
finding P of A union B?
From high school maths,
probably?
No idea?
OK.
P of A union B is equal to P of
A plus P of B minus P of A
intersection B. Because if you
consider P of A, you would
have taken this full circle.
When you take P of
B, you would have
taken this full circle.
So which means you're counting
this area twice.
So here, we deduct it once.
OK?
Great.
So this is the basics
of the probability.
Now, actually we looked at two
events, two joint events here.
But we should have
a formal way of
looking at multiple events.
So how can we do that?
The first way is doing
it by trees.
Let's say we represent
the outcome of the
first trial by a branch.
We can represent the outcome of
the second trial by another
branch from these two
previous branches.
So this would be
H HH HT TH TT.
And we know this could happen
with probability 1/2.
So we know it's, again,
1/2, 1/2, 1/2, 1/2.
So this is 1/4.
Suppose we want to do this for
an outcome of throwing dice.
Then, probably we would
have 6 branches here.
Which, again, forks into
another 36 branches.
So there should be another
easier way.
For that, we could use a second
method call grid.
We could simply put
that in a diagram.
So this is the first trial.
And this will be our
second trial.
So now, we can represent any
possible outcome on this grid.
For example, can give you me an
example where you throw the
same number in both
the trials?
Then, what would be the layout
of it in this grid?
Throwing the same number
in both the trials.
Here's the first trial.
This, the second.
Then it would be the diagonal.
If you want to calculate the
probability, do you know the
probability is the ratio between
the outcomes we expect
over all possible outcomes?
So here, we know there will
be 6 instances in this
highlighted area.
Compare that, 36 to
all possibilities.
So it'll be simpler 6/36.
How can you find the probability
of getting a
cumulative total of, say, 6?
Then again, it would
be very simple.
It could be 1, 5; 2, 4;
3, 3; 4, 2; 1, 5.
All right?
So it'll be 5 by 36.
OK?
So either by using trees or
grid, you can easily find the
probabilities.
Now, let's look at a few
concrete examples.
Let's see.
Suppose we are throwing
three coins.
Then, what is the probability
of one particular outcome in
that trial, in all
three trials?
What is the probability,
assuming that these are
unbiased coins?
What is the probability of
one particular outcome?
Because how many possible
outcomes are there if you are
throwing three coins?
Consider this tree.
First, it splits into 2.
Then, it splits into 4.
Then?
8, all right?
OK, so there are 8 possible
outcomes.
So each outcome will have
the probability 1/8.
so what is the probability of
heads appearing exactly twice?
How can you do that?
Of course, you can write
the tree and count.
What is the easier way
of doing that?
Since we know this count, since
we know this probability
of a particular event
happening?
How can we come up with
the probability of
getting exactly 2 heads?
It could be head, head, or
tail-- so this is by
enumerating all the
possible outcomes.
So it could have been head,
head, tail, where me put the
tail only at the end.
It could have been
head, tail, head.
Or it could have been
tail, head, head.
In these three cases, you're
getting exactly 2 heads.
So we are enumerating all
possible outcomes.
And we know each possible
outcome will take the
probability 1/8.
So the total probability
here is 3/8.
OK?
So this is one way of handling
a probability question.
You can do that only because
these are independent events.
And you can sum them.
We'll come to that later.
Suppose you are rolling
two four-sided dice.
And assuming they're fair,
how many possible
outcomes are there?
Two four-sided dice, and
assuming that each of them are
fair-- that means unbiased--
how many possible outcomes
are there?
Consider this tree.
First, it branches into 4, OK?
In the first trial, it's a
four-sided dice, so there are
4 possible outcomes.
So it branches into 4.
Then, each branch will,
in turn, fork
into another 4 branches.
So there are totally
16 outcomes.
So what is the probability
of rolling a 2 and a 3?
What is the probability of
rolling a 2 and a 3?
Not in a given order, not
in the given order.
Can anyone give the answer?
OK, let's see.
So we have to roll
a 2 and a 3.
So which means it could have
been 2, 3, or 3, 2.
And we know the probability
of each event is 1/16.
So this will be 1/16.
And this will be 1/16.
So the total probability
is 1/8.
What is the probability of
getting the sum of the rolls
an odd number?
What is the probability of
getting an odd number as sum
of the rolls?
Now, this is getting a bit
tricky because now it's maybe
a bit harder to enumerate
all possible cases.
So how can we do that?
There should be a short cut.
AUDIENCE: It can either
be odd or even.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: You can either
get odd or even.
PROFESSOR: It can be either
odd or even, right?
So it will be 1/2.
OK, there's another trick we
might be able to use to get
the answers quickly.
What is the probability of the
first roll being equal to the
second roll?
In the same line,
you can think.
What is the probability of
getting the first roll equal
to the second roll?
It's quite similar to this.
Any ideas?
It's a four-sided dice.
There are 4 possible outcomes.
This is one case where it could
be 1, 1, or it could be
2, 2, or 3, 3, or 4, 4.
And if it's inside a dice,
it would be n, right?
So if it's n-sided dice, there
and n possible outcomes
desired, and totally
n by n outcomes.
So you get 1/n probability.
What is the probability of at
least 1 roll equal to 4?
At least 1 roll equal to 4?
This is very interesting.
These type of questions,
you'll get in
that Psets, I know.
Probably in the quiz, too.
What is the probability
of getting at least 1
roll equal to 4?
OK, so what are the
possible outcomes?
First roll, could be a 4.
And the second roll
could be anything.
Or it could be 4, and
the first roll
could have been anything.
Or both could have been 4, but
we would have considered that
here, as well.
So what we had to do is we had
to calculate this probability
and this probability, add them,
and deduct this, because
this would have been
double counted.
It's quite like, this
intersection.
We want to remove that, and we
want to find the union OK?
So what is this probability?
Since we don't care about the
second roll, we have to care
only about the first roll,
our first roll
getting 4, which is 1/4.
And this is 1/4 similarly.
And this is 1/4 by
1/4, so 1/16.
So it'll be 1/2 minus 1/16.
And when you give the answers,
if it's hard, you can just
leave it like this.
So this is what we call giving
the answers as formula instead
of giving exact fractions.
Because sometimes it might be
hard to find the fraction.
Suppose it's something like 1
over, say, 2 to the power 5
and a 3 to the 2, something
like this.
Or we'll say 5.
You're not supposed to give the
exact value in this amount
or even the fractions.
You can give such formulas.
You can give something like
this, too, to give the inverse
probability of that
not happening.
Let's see.
Let's move into a little bit
more complicated example.
A pack of cards--
what is the probability
of getting an ace?
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: 1 out of 2?
PROFESSOR: 1 out of 2?
AUDIENCE: out of 52.
PROFESSOR: Not a particular--
an ace, yes, just ace.
AUDIENCE: Is it 4 out of 52?
PROFESSOR: 4/52, yes.
Or if you consider one
suit, it would have
been like 1/13, right?
You could have considered
one suit, and out of--
OK.
It's the same analysis, right?
What is the probability of
getting a specific card, which
means, say, the ace of hearts?
It's what she said,
yeah, 1/52.
What is the probability
of not getting an ace?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: 1 minus--
PROFESSOR: 1/13.
OK, this is where me make you
solve the inverse probability.
OK, so that will come into
play very often.
OK, now let's get into two
decks of playing cards.
OK, what is the sample size?
What is the sample size
of drawing cards from
two decks of cards?
Two cards, actually.
You're going to draw two cards
from two different decks.
Sorry?
OK.
What is the sample size of
drawing a card from one deck?
There are 52 possible
outcomes.
So for each outcome here, we
have 52 outcomes there, right?
So it's 52 by 52.
It's like the tree, but here,
we have 52 branches.
So eventually, you will
have 52 by 52.
This is where you can't
enumerate all
the possible cases.
So you should have a way
to find the final
probability, OK?
So in this case, what is the
probability of getting at
least one ace?
What's the probability of
getting at least one ace?
This is, again, similar
to this case.
Remember this diagram.
It's called Venn diagram.
Remember this.
So what is the probability of
getting at least one ace,
which means you could have got
the ace from the first deck,
or the second deck, or both.
But if you're getting from both,
you have to deduct it
because otherwise, you would
have double counted it.
So getting an ace from the
first deck is 1/13.
Second deck, 1/13.
Getting from both
is 1/52 by 52.
Sorry, 1/13 by 1/13.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Are you adding them?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's what
I explained earlier.
You're doing two trials.
You could have got the
ace from here.
And this could have
been anything.
You could have got the ace from
here, and this could have
been anything.
You could have got
an ace from both.
So you should add these two
probabilities because we need
a case where at least
one card is ace.
But the problem is, this could
have happened here and here.
And so you will deduct it.
What is the probability of
getting neither card--
what is the probability of
neither card being an ace?
AUDIENCE: 1 minus that?
PROFESSOR: 1 minus
this, exactly.
OK, you're getting comfortable
with the
inverse probability now.
What's the probability of two
cards from the same suit?
What is the probability
of getting two cards
from the same suit?
Now, it's getting interesting.
Two cards from the same suit.
So how can we think
about this?
Of course, you can enumerate all
possible cases and count.
We don't want to do that.
OK, you're going to use the grid
here to visualize this.
OK?
It could have been a
spades, or hearts,
or clubs, or a diamond.
So we want two cards of
the same suit, right?
So it's 4/16 possible
outcomes.
Do you see that?
So see, we are using
all the tools
available at our disposal--
trees, grids, counting, Ven
diagrams, inverse probability.
Yeah, you should be able to
do that to get the answers
quickly because you could have
actually done-- you could have
done something like this, too.
But it will take more
time, right?
So this will be a simpler way
of visualizing things.
What is the probability of
getting neither card a diamond
nor a club?
Neither card is diamond
nor club.
That is tricky.
But since we have this grid, we
can easily visualize that.
So if neither card is diamond
nor club, then it could have
been only these two
values, right?
Which is, again, 4/16.
So there are 4 possible cases.
OK?
So what is the summary?
What is the take home
message here?
In probability, the probability
of the belief, or
the way of expressing
the belief, of a
particular event happening.
Now, there could be several
possible outcomes.
Out of those possible outcomes,
you have a certain
number of desired outcomes.
How can you find that?
You can either enumerate
all of them.
You can put them in a tree, or
you can put them in a grid.
Or you can use some sort of Venn
diagram and come up with
some sort of analysis.
Here, we start with our belief
that the coin is unbiased, or
we have a fair chance
of drawing any card
from the deck of cards.
So we have all these unbiased
beliefs, or beliefs about the
characteristics of each trial.
So we start from that.
Then, we find the probability
of a particular event
happening in a certain
number of trials.
But what if you don't have the
knowledge about the coin?
What if you don't know whether
it's fair or not?
What if you don't know P of A is
equal to H is equal to 1/2?
Suppose you don't know that.
Suppose it's P. How
can you find it?
What you could do is you
could simulate this.
You can throw coin several
times and count the total
number of heads you get, OK?
So it could be n of heads
over n trial will
give you the P, right?
This is a way of finding the
probabilities through a
certain number of trials.
It's like simulating
the experiments.
It's called Monte Carlo
simulation.
And using that, we try
to find a particular
parameter of the model.
You know how they actually found
the value of pi at the
beginning, pi?
It's again using a Monte
Carlo simulation.
What you could do is for a given
radius, you can actually
check whether it lies within
a circle or not.
You can simulate the Monte
Carlo simulation.
And given this radius, you can
come up with a particular
location at random and check
whether it's within this
boundary or not, OK?
So then, you know the outcome.
You know the outcomes, right?
So suppose this is n_a, And
the total outcome is n_t.
This gives you the
area, right?
We know this is r-squared,
and this is pi r-squared.
Sorry.
When this is 4 r-squared,
this is 2r, right?
So using this, you can
easily calculate pi.
So now, since we are going to
come up with these parameters
through repeating the trials, we
need to have a standardized
way of finding these
parameters.
We can't simply say
this, right?
Take this example.
You know this MIT
shuttle right?
A shuttle arriving at the
right time, or the time
difference between the arrival
and the actual quoted time can
be plotted in a graph.
So if you put that it is
spread around 0, right?
Probably, or we hope so.
OK?
Now, from this, we can see that
actually the mean of this
simulation will give you the
expected difference in the
time, the expected difference
in the arrival time from the
actual quoted time.
And we hope this expectation
to be 0.
We call that mean.
Means is taking the average.
But this distribution might
actually give you some
information, some extra
information, as well.
That is, how well we can
actually believe this, how
much we can rely on this.
If the spread is greater,
something like this, then
probably you might actually not
trust the system, right?
Although the mean is 0,
it's going to come
early or late, right?
Which means it's useless.
Similarly, in this case, we have
a spread around mean 0.
But if you take the score, the
marks you get for 600, it
could be something like this.
It's not centered
around 0, right?
Hopefully.
It's probably, say, 50.
Then, we actually want the
spread to be small or large?
We want the spread to be large
because we want to distinguish
the levels, right?
The students' level
of understanding.
600.
Anyway, so the spread determines
what is the
variation percent in their
distribution of the scores?
We measure that by a variable
called standard deviation.
In this case, this particular
sample will be different from
its mean by a particular
value, right?
We can express that as
x_i minus its mean.
Let's call the mean mu.
So this would be
the difference.
Standard deviation is summing
up all the differences.
But the problem is, when you sum
up the differences, it'll
be 0, right?
The total summation of the
differences will be 0 if
that's how you get the mean
because if you expand this,
it'll be something
like this, right?
Which will be n mu.
Should be equal to 0.
So we have to sum, or
actually take the
differences into account.
So, let's square this.
So now, it will no
longer be 0.
Now, this gives 0,
the differences.
It's the squared sum of the
differences averaged across
all the samples.
We call this variance.
And the square root of
variance is standard deviation.
OK?
Now, having a standard
deviation--
so we know the standard
deviation tells you how spread
the distribution is.
But can we actually rely only
on the standard deviation to
determine the consistency
of some event?
Can we?
Probably not.
Suppose take two examples,
one is the scores, 50.
And suppose the standard
deviation is minus
10, plus 10, OK?
So the standard deviation
is 10 here.
Suppose it lies in this form.
Consider another example, the
weight, the weight of the
people, like say at MIT.
And suppose it's centered
around 150.
Now, if the standard deviation
is, say, 10, then the standard
deviation 10 here and the
standard deviation 10 here
don't convey the same
message, OK?
So we need to have a different
way of expressing the
consistency of a distribution.
So we represent it by
coefficient of variation,
which is equal to the standard
deviation divided by mean.
Now here, it will be 10/150.
Here, it will be 10/50.
So we know this is more
consistent than this.
The weights of the students at
MIT, it's more consistent than
the marks you might get,
or you get, for 600.
It might be true.
Now, what is for the use of
the standard deviation?
How can we use that?
Let's look at this graph where
suppose the mean is 0 and the
standard deviation is, say, 5.
Consider another example where
standard deviation is 10.
It might have been
like this, OK?
Now, before that, let me sort
of digress a little bit so I
can explain this better.
We can take the outcome of a
particular event as a sample
in our distribution.
So suppose you're
throwing a die.
So you get an outcome.
You can represent that outcome
as a distribution, OK?
So here, there's x, which
can take 1 to, say, 6.
And we can represent x_i as
a sample point in our
distribution.
So I don't know, it might be
uniform, probably, we hope.
So it's with 1/6 probability,
we always take
one of these values.
OK.
But this might not be the
case with all events.
OK, so what I'm trying to say
here is you can actually
represent the outcome of the
trial in the distribution.
Or you can also represent the
probability of something
happening in a distribution.
How does it work?
OK, in this case, we
throw our dice.
We get an outcome.
We go and put it
in the x-axis.
It could be between 1 and 6.
And it takes this
distribution.
In addition, what you could
do is you could
have, say, 100 trials.
So you throw a coin.
You take 100 trials.
You get the mean, you get the
probability of getting a head.
And you have that mean, right?
So probability of getting
a head for 100
trials, say, 0.51.
You do another 100 trials,
you got another one.
So you have now another
distribution.
So there's a distribution
of probabilities.
So you can have a distribution
of probabilities, or you can
have a distribution
for the events.
We handle these two cases
in the p-set.
So probably you should be able
to distinguish those two.
Anyway, so here in this
particular example, let's take
this as our mu.
Let's take this as our
standard deviation.
And for the first distribution,
let's take the
standard deviation to be 5.
When the standard deviation
is great, it's
going to be more spread.
It's going to be more
distributed than the former.
So here, say the standard
deviation is 10.
The standard deviation is a
way of expressing how many
items, how many samples are
going to lie between those
particular boundaries.
So for a normal distribution, we
know the exact area, exact
probability of things
happening.
If there's no mu, we know within
the first standard
deviation, there will be 68%
of events lie in that area.
Within two standard
deviations--
OK, one standard
deviation, 68%.
Two standard deviations
on either side,
it's going to be 95%.
Three standard deviations,
it's going to be 99%.
So suppose you conducted
so many trials.
And you get the values.
And in the distribution, suppose
mu, mean, is 10, and
the standard deviation
is, say, 1.
So now, with 99% confidence, we
can say then the outcome of
the next trial is going
to be between what?
7 and 13, right?
So this is where finding the
distribution and standard
deviation helps us giving
a confidence interval,
expressing our belief of that
particular event happening.
We will look at a few examples
because you might need this in
your p-set.
So this particular
function you have
already seen in the lecture.
But we need to understand
this particular part.
Suppose you have a probability
of something happening.
Suppose you estimated
the probability
of something happening.
Suppose you're given the
coin is biased, OK?
Sorry, unbiased.
So we know p of H
is equal to 1/2.
How can we simulate
an outcome?
How can you simulate an outcome
and see whether it's a
head or a tail with this
particular probability?
We do that by calling this
function, random.random(),
which is going to give you a
random value between 0 and 1.
And you're going to
check whether it's
below this or not.
If it's below this, we
can take it as head.
If it's not, it's tail.
And this will happen with
probability 1/2, because the
random function is going to
return a value between 0 and 1
with equal probabilities.
It's uniform probabilities.
So to simulate a head or tail,
you call that function.
You write the expression
like that, OK?
Then, if you consider this
example, for a certain number
of flips, we simulate
the event.
And we count the number
of heads we obtain.
And also from that, you
can calculate the
number of tails as well.
If you know the total flips, you
know the number of tails.
Using that, we are taking
two ratios.
Now, the ratio between the
heads and tails, and the
difference between
heads and tails.
We are doing this for certain
number of trials.
And we're going to take the mean
and standard deviation of
these trials, OK?
So here in our distribution,
what are we considering?
What is going to build our
distribution here?
The ratios, right?
The ratios of the events.
And we simulated certain number
of trials to get those
events, OK?
Only if you simulate certain
number of trials, you can
actually summarize the outcome
of the events in mean and
standard deviation.
This is exactly like the
difference in the times of the
bus arriving and the
quoted times.
Let's check this example.
Let's plot this and see.
It's going to take a while.
OK, that's another thing I want
to explain here because
since you're going to
be going to plot--
we are going to use PyLab
extensively and plot graphs.
You'll need to put a title and
labels to all the plots you're
generating.
Plus, you can use this
text to actually put
the text in the graph.
We will show that in a while.
Plus--
here, sorry.
If you want to change the axis
to log-log scale, you can call
this comma at the end after
calling the plot.
Because you might sometimes need
to change the axis to log
scale in x and y-axis.
So this is the mean,
heads versus tails.
And if you can see it, the mean
tends to be 1 when we
have a large number of flips.
So to get the consistency,
we need to simulate
large number of trials.
Then only it will tend to be
close to the mean, OK?
This is sort of a way of
checking the evolution of the
series by actually doing it for
a certain number of flips
at every time.
So it's quite like
a scatter plot.
A scatter plot is like plotting
the outcomes of our
experiments.
Suppose it's x1 and
x2 in a graph.
So we are going to say--
so for example, suppose you
have a variable, and the
variable causes an outcome--
a probability of the coin flip,
so p of H. And it can
result in a certain number of
heads appearing, say n of H.
Now, you can do a scatter plot
between these two variables.
And it will be probably
a spread.
But we know that if you increase
the probability of
heads, the number of heads is
going to increase as well.
So it would be probably
something like this.
From this, we can assume
that it's linear or
something like that.
But the scatter plot is actually
representing the
outcomes of the trial versus
some other variable in the
graph and visualize it.
And let me show the last
graph, and we'll
be done with that.
So this, again, we actually
know, instead of putting a
scatter plot, we're actually
giving the distribution as a
histogram and printing a
text box in the graph.
This might be useful if you want
to display something on
your graph.
I guess we will be uploading
the code to the site.
So you can check the code
if you want later, OK?
Sure.
See you next week.